your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
but we are in the midst of the fourth
Industrial Revolution which accelerates
Global change Global Energy Systems Food
Systems and Supply chains will be deeply
affected
it means
investing
into a green loan so for more
sustainable economy climate change can
lead to an Extinction
large parts of our global population
foreign
in a couple of years business could well
be hopping to the people in charge
really want us to eat bugs ancient
Elites were inspired to see people they
invent anything you can think of but no
it's it's complete nonsense a company is
called insect this is the insect protein
just been approved by the EU
infiltrated the governments of the
Netherlands it's quite open now he's
open about it so no conspiracy theory
whatsoever nobody forces people to eat
the insects
[Music]
I'm Nicole Kidman and I am going to eat
a full course meal of bugs
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight